hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a 2017 american science fiction
and action movie called valyrian and the
city of a thousand planets
the movie begins with a montage of a
space station called alpha which is
being built over many decades
it is completed in 2020
since then alpha has become a center for
various species from all over the
universe to gather and live peacefully
the captain of the space station is very
happy to welcome every newcomer that
stops by the alpha however the president
of the world state federation states
that alpha eventually has become a
threat to earth due to its massive size
and weight because of that the space
station has to be released from the
earth's gravity and it will journey into
the unknown carrying a message of peace
and unity
400 years after the release on the
planet mole a human-like creature called
princess leho wakes up from her sleep
with his pet called the converter she
steps out of her home to the beautiful
surroundings in her world
she then greets other mole inhabitants
called the pearls who are gathering
pearls on the seashore one of them hands
over a pearl to leho
she gives it to the converter and it
magically produces a huge amount of
pearls giving them back to nature as the
emperor says a few moments later while
admiring the beauty of the planet
suddenly multiple vessels start breaking
through the atmosphere and falling down
from the sky
the emperor haben immediately orders his
men to evacuate all the people into a
safer place as the ensuing explosion
caused by the fallen huge spaceship
starts to destroy the entire planet they
manage to hide in a broken vessel and
seal its door but unfortunately the door
handle is broken leho fails to make it
to the ship
haban looks at his daughter through the
window for the last time while his wife
aloy cries in sorrow before the
explosion hits her leho emits a signal
throughout the galaxy
this signal goes through major valyrian
who is enjoying his great time on a
virtual beach which makes him shocked
not long after his partner sergeant
laura lean approaches him and they start
teasing each other as they walk towards
the cockpit the sergeant denies that she
is in love with valerian because she is
aware that the major has a long list of
conquests he admits that laureline is
different and wants his heart to belong
to her and no one else before the ship
leaves the exo space valyrian tells his
ai assistant alex that he had a weird
dream about a girl in which the aia
can't verify the identity
they arrive safely at planetkirian with
a mission to recover the converter and
bring it back to alpha the minister
claims that the converter is the last
creature of its species which makes it
very valuable the field team are
surprised when they see valerian and
laureline dress like tourists on a
military mission the major is dropped at
a market where valerian awkwardly asks
his partner to marry him but she doesn't
answer him and continues her journey the
market is a place where tourists use
special devices to experience walking
through alien stores by putting on the
helmet the visitors can see the
invisible alien stores
on the other side of the market the rest
of the team arrive and laureline shoots
a guard alien with a tracker allowing
another agent to take control over his
body the major enters the market while
laureline catches up with him through
the back door valerian eventually
arrives at the target store and meets
with sergeant cooper who hands him over
glasses and a transmatter box to bring
anything there he also scans him with a
special device which makes him invisible
meanwhile two mysterious cap creatures
from planet mole including emperor sun
tsuori enter the store and negotiate
with the store owner higon they attempt
to trade the last converter with pearls
igon seems unwilling to make the
agreement leading to a standoff
not long after the invisible valyrian
sneaks in and forces a gun to hand over
the converter which he stole from the
federation to him while pointing his gun
at his head the major takes the pearl
and the converter and then goes away
from there
however the box on his arm becomes
visible and attracts the guard there
he shoots him with a lot of magnetic
balls which are attached to his box arm
causing him to fall many levels below
the market he ends up in a room where he
meets an annoying alien child
valerian manages to release all the
magnetic balls however he upsets the kid
in front of his mother making her
furious and chases after him
luckily the major successfully escapes
from the room and eventually meets up
with laura lean again
she is fixing her partner's arm while
the gone unleashes his beast to go after
valerian
the team realized the threat and they
immediately run back to the tour bus
they depart and head back to the ship
but the beast keeps chasing after them
and manages to break into the bus
tearing it apart their weapons are
ineffective against the beast
valyrian and lauraleen leap to their
spaceship followed by the beast
however the two fly high enough to enter
the exospace sending it falling back to
the ground
valerian discovers that the woman in his
dream came from planet mull the same
planet where the pearl was produced
however alex claims that the planet no
longer exists
when he attempts to dig more information
the access is restricted and only a man
who holds a five stars rank can access
it not long after the two arrive at
alpha station a place that currently
accommodates more than 30 million lives
and more than 3 000 species
upon arrival they are welcomed by
commander arun phillip who explains that
a radioactive zone magically occurs in
the middle of the station and it can
destroy the entire alpha within a week
the couple are assigned by the minister
to protect the commander in the mission
despite him having a unit of ruthless
robot killers named k-tron protecting
him
on the other side the commander secretly
keeps a native from planet mole captive
she is tortured and he commands his men
to keep trying to get information from
her before the council meeting lauraleen
refuses to give the converter to the
commander since it's the last living
species specimen and philip wants to
sell it all stakeholders of alpha are
gathered together where the commander
explains the current condition of the
contaminated radioactive zone
outside the room lauraleen is approached
by three talking pigeons who offer her
information about planet mole they
reveal that major samp who was an expert
on planet mole died mysteriously they
are willing to give more information
about the planet in exchange for the
converter but are rejected by her
suddenly the pearls break into the
meeting room and start shooting everyone
with blue slime which incapacitated all
of them
after everyone is paralyzed they take
the commander away it turns out that
valyrian has prepared a spider robot
that cuts through the shell and free him
from there he immediately seeks out for
his partner and subsequently free her
with his special spacesuit valerian
pursues the commander and the pearls
through different and hard terrains
while lauraleen and the others assist
him from the control room the pearls
reach their alien ship and immediately
head over to the center of alpha which
is the radiative zone valyrian is picked
up by his spaceship and continues the
pursuit after a very long and
challenging chase the pearls in the
major enter the red zone causing the
control room to lose contact with him
lauraleen attempts to go after him to
the red zone but the general prevents
her from doing so and orders his men to
restrain her
not long after she tricks the guards and
manages to knock them out the talking
pigeons bring her to a pirate named bob
and pay him to take them to a jellyfish
that can track valerian's location
on the other hand the general tries to
get information about planet mull but he
doesn't have the authority to access the
file which makes him suspicious that
someone is hiding something
they arrive at a place full of
bromosaurs and acquire the requested
jellyfish almost get killed by the
bromosaurs they manage to return to the
initial position where lauraleen puts it
on her head for a minute to track his
major
she figures out the place and
immediately goes over there she locates
valerian and his crashed spaceship at
the center of alpha station and gives
him medicine which works effectively
the general finds the room where a
native of planet mole is being held and
sets her free
she reveals that they attack them
because they have something they need
lauraleen gets baited by a beautiful
butterfly and is pulled up to the edge
where a giant alien captures her and
takes her away
valyrian gets himself pulled up and
shoots the alien's head
since there is no way to get inside the
giant alien's base he has to go to a
sketchy part of alpha that is filled by
crooks and prostitutes to find a
glamopod
on the other side the giant alien forces
laureline to wear a weird dress she
refuses to wear it but they seem don't
understand each other unfortunately he
is spotted by a club owner named jolly
and he invites valerian to watch a
special dance performance by a glamopod
called bubble he is amazed with her
talent because she is able to change
clothes in a nick of time while dancing
after watching her mesmerizing
performance he asks for bubbles help to
rescue lauraleen
at first she refuses to help him forcing
valyrian to pull his gun out bubble is
shocked and transforms into her real
appearance while the major shoots the
pimp after valerian promises her to set
her free she finally agrees to help him
bubble consumes valyrian and transforms
into the giant alien
they manage to get into the base where a
ceremony is taking place and they
discover lauraleen is being brought as a
sacrifice to the alien king
she almost gets her head chopped while
valyrian and bubble intervene and show
off their fighting skills killing the
king and his men they attempt to escape
but they are confronted by another group
of aliens they eventually managed to
escape through a vent with bubble
however bubble was wounded in the
process
as she dies valerian tells her that she
is the greatest dancer he has ever seen
because of the commander's absence the
minister orders the general to take the
command and grants him full access to
fill its data the couple travel deeper
to the center of alpha until they
discover a colorful barrier
they break through the barrier and are
welcomed by the pearl's emperor and his
wife
it is revealed that princess leo
deliberately chose valerian to be the
guardian of her soul before she died
having tells them that planet mole was
once a true paradise until it was
destroyed because of a brutal war
happening outside the planet he reveals
that it was commander phillip who called
out the order to strike a gigantic alien
spaceship with special missiles causing
it to fall down and demolish the entire
planet he adds that the survivors made
it out by hiding in a half-destroyed
ship they adapted and learned languages
mathematics etc they ended up in alpha
and finally realized that they can
rebuild their own world with a pearl and
a converter which both valerian and
lauraleen possess have been states that
they have forgiven humans for destroying
their home
he then wakes the commander up and he
admits that he had to do it major samk
warned him but the commander kept
insisting on launching the airstrike
phillip then decided to kill sam to
eliminate any living witnesses
lauraleen convinces valerian to give
them the converter and disobey the order
to give it back to their superiors
using these two items the pearls rebuild
a mini planet mole within their
spaceship
outside the barrier the general's army
arrives plants explosive bombs and hold
their position waiting for a command
on the other side valerian and laura
lean attempt to call the general
requesting to call off the assault the
general believes them
however phillip orders his k-tron robot
to attack everyone outside the barrier
killing several pearls and soldiers
valerian shows up and joins the fight
eliminating the k-tron the pearls
managed to leave with their spaceship on
time
luckily the countdown is stopped before
the bombs destroy the pearl's home for
the second time
meanwhile the general orders his men to
arrest commander philip for the crime he
had committed at the end of the movie
valerian once again proposes to
lauraleen with a pearl this time she
accepts the proposal and the two of them
kiss
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching